you
[Music]
my name's Sorum I'm an engineer on ML
platform machine learning platform and
lift and today I want to speak a little
bit about the technical decisions we
made around building a scalable machine
learning platform I want to get start by
talking about problems that we're trying
to solve and then get into some of the
details of how we approach the solutions
how many people out here have used lift
before just raise of hand raise hands
please okay so most of the audiences and
so let's talk about the classic lift
experience you open your app you're
trying to put your pickup spot and
destination select a payment method and
call a ride when this process underlying
this process there's a lot of machine
learning that's happening we can smartly
pick the pickup spot from a very noisy
GPS data to know exactly where you might
be then we can also do some predictions
on what are the most likely destinations
you want to go to based on your ride
history based on your previous ride you
took we might be able to pick
automatically a payment method if you
have several of those maybe use a
different card during computer hours
compared to a business trip that you're
on or are during weekend rides we can
run machine learning models to optimize
what driver gets dispatched to you or
predicting the ETA of your ride from
your source to destination or picking up
the right matching passengers if you are
taking a shared ride so every part of
the experience has machine learning
powering it we have hundreds of machine
learning researchers working on just the
classic lyft experience aside from that
we have a ton of people working on
autonomous driving using deep learning
extensively for computer vision planning
and mapping so my team's job is to
build out a machine learning platform
that makes it easy to develop new models
prototype many different approaches to
pure machine learning model once you
have a few models that you have selected
we want to make it easy for you to try
out different training algorithms for
example if you're you might want to
tweak the learning rate on your model
and try out different learning rate try
out different optimizers how can we make
it easy to scale out one model that
you've developed and run many executions
of those with different hyper parameters
once you have a model that performs the
best we also make it easy for you
to ship that into production there are
different paths to production for a
model that runs during the web request
for serving a ride it needs to be served
as a web service other models may do
some kind of offline prediction on a
daily basis or on a weekly basis for
example figuring out the right
population to send out an incentive to
there is a third type of inference which
might be a machine learning model
running on the edge for example in an
autonomous car so how can we make it
easy across all these different types of
deployments for research science to go
through this life cycle of model
development training and production so
research scientists spend a lot of time
doing non modeling tasks today if you're
if you've if the audience is full of
people who are building their own models
you might realize you spend a lot of
time collecting the right data set
querying it filtering it
slice and dice it to generate the
correct training error and then if your
training really compute-intensive models
like deep learning models you need to be
able to provision the right hardware for
your model you might want to run many
different iterations of those models you
need good logging and monitoring and our
team's job is to make all of that simple
so I'm gonna get into some of those
requirements to start we wanted to build
a system that's framework agnostic the
current landscape of machine learning is
so rapidly changing there are some
really great frameworks like tensorflow
pi torch that have come up in the last
few years and then there is the whole
psychic learn ecosystem or boosted trees
certainly any new libraries that might
come up so we want to support any
arbitrary framework and not be tied into
an implementation for a specific
framework support for GPU workloads
almost all deep learning models are
extremely computer intensive several
orders of magnitude more than
traditional machine learning approaches
and we want to serve those internal
customers to lift who are training very
large scale models that feed imagery or
video data and can have model training
that can run for days how can we make
their job easier and support single GPU
multi-gpu or distributed training
workloads we wanted the system to be
clouded Gnostic and the main reason for
that is along with the software
ecosystem the hardware ecosystem for
machine learning is also rapidly
evolving a study by open AI shows
there's almost 10x improvement year over
year in ml compute performance which is
extremely fast and there are custom
accelerators ASIC based model training
systems that are being developed NVIDIA
has the volta GPU which is the current
state of the art GPU for model training
however Google is working on TPU chips
that there are custom Asics built for
model training and we wanted to
be able to leverage any of this hardware
because we cannot anticipate exactly how
the Seco system is going to move so we
wanted to be cloud agnostic now with a
lot of power comes a lot of
responsibility is rising however we have
many levels of users we have researchers
who come from a academic background and
don't really want to deal with a lot of
infrastructure problems they don't want
to get into the nitty gritties of how
certain infrastructure is set up to
launch their jobs however for some
advanced use cases such as distributed
training or if you want to build custom
apps for your tensorflow model we also
have very advanced program software
engineer users who want to get the
maximum flexibility around defining
their models so we wanted to support
both such use cases so we decided to use
container docker containers as our
primary abstraction for most of our jobs
this solves a lot of problems around
dependency management it makes it easy
to be framework agnostic as long as you
can package your code into a docker
image you can run it on our system now
with containers we need to decide a good
execution engine for those containers
and the kubernetes ecosystem has really
blown blown up in the last few years
kubernetes provides a very rich set of
api's for launching very complex
workloads you can scale out very easily
using kubernetes on any of the cloud
providers it provides a cloud agnostic
api first to launch jobs which can then
translate from either AWS to google
flower to any custom deployments it
handles a lot of different
infrastructure challenges that we would
have to design on iran for example and
i'll get into some of the details
one of the challenges with using
kubernetes however is its power it is
very complex there's very low level
api's that most users may not want to
deal with so I'll show how we create the
right abstractions to help our users
launch all kinds of workloads we decided
to go the route of providing easy path
that is fully UI based so we have our
own UI based system internally we call
it left alone that allows a data
scientist to go from developing in
Jupiter notebooks to containerize in
their models to running very large-scale
hyper parameter search and then
deployments
however for advanced users we provide a
much lower level api using command line
to give them full flexibility for
defining their machine learning
workloads so let's go through some of
those features notebooks this is the
entry point to any researchers machine
learning development flow you want to
have an interactive environment where
you can easily query datasets build out
different stages of your model
development and try it out and Jupiter
is the de facto standard right now for a
lot of these model developments so this
is lift learn on the left side you see
the different functionality we provide
and the first functionalities
environments which are Jupiter
environments for developing either
Python or R models we are moving quickly
towards Python as our standard
programming language for most workloads
just because it provides us really great
into an integration from development to
production izing so in this environment
I can quickly pick a software
environment that I would like to launch
so we provide some pre baked software
environments here you can see I have
four different environments one which is
the standard docker image containing
most of
my commonly used Python libraries and
next to it is a deep learning plus
tensor tensor board image in the in the
standard image we only launched a
jupiter notebook however with the deep
running image we can launch both
notebooks as well as tensile board
tensile board is a visualization tool
that tensorflow
and our pythons use for measuring your
learning performance over time
similarly we allow different teams
within left to provide their own
software environments in the form of
docker images so if you care about a
certain set of requirements which are
different from most users and you want
to pin different versions of
scikit-learn or you use a RC branch on
tensorflow you can do that and provide
there's a custom environment right here
next you pick the hardware resources you
want to run this job on so we provide
some pre-configured Hardware
environments you can choose many
different configurations of CPU memory
and GPU that you would like for your job
for your notebooks having some fixed
environment chart choices makes it easy
for users to quickly go through this
flow however you can use the command
line tools to arbitrarily create any
kind of environment which translates to
kubernetes resources behind the API so
you click Next and now you have a new
environment set up for you now you can
see we already provide a link to the
notebook right there in the UI you click
on it and we'll take you to your Jupiter
environment where you can start
developing your models
in the background this is these are some
of the links that are available to you
once you launch the job you have the
notebook interface where you can develop
any moral and you have the tensor board
for visualizing any model training that
you might be running on it in the
background we're creating kubernetes
objects the primarily one being a part
pods are the lowest execution units
inside kubernetes and you can configure
many different containers to run inside
a pod so here we are launching a pod
with a given set of Python requirements
along with the right resource requests
that the user submitted it picks up a
certain image but you can use using it
as a docker image gives you full
flexibility to pick the image you would
like to run along with the pod we attach
certain volumes our volume can represent
either a temporary disk space the user
might want for loading some datasets or
generating some training artifacts such
as checkpoints intermediate checkpoints
for your models we can also we also
mount NFS into these parts so we have
AWS EFS which we mount as a persistent
volume on each notebook the primary use
case there is a user can just start a
new notebook start developing a new
model save their notebooks on the EFS
and once you're done you can terminate
the environments come back again next
day and start where you left off so it's
it makes good use of the resources by
letting you checkpoint all your work and
come back to it layer at a later point
we also provide github base integration
so let's say you've done all your
iteration and now you want to push this
code out for review then you can log
into github from your notebook interface
directly and push it out as a as
new poll requester has a new commit we
also launched services and ingress these
are other object types in kubernetes
which allow you external access to any
kubernetes links so in this case my
notebook URL is actually a kubernetes
ingress backed by elastic load balancer
which allows any user to access the
notebook over the Internet so what are
some of the challenges we faced while
building this some of these machine
learning images are extremely big in
size on average our notebook images are
between 12 to 15 gigs in size and just
downloading because it contains cuda
drivers it contains the whole cuda
toolkit it has all the binaries for
tensorflow pi torch supporting python 2
and 3 and all other frameworks that
users might want so loading a new job
can become a bottleneck because it might
take a long time to download these
images so what we do is we create a warm
cache of images commonly used images on
every single node on the kubernetes
cluster that's one of our approaches for
pre-caching most commonly used images
directly available on every single node
this helps us eliminate half of our boot
up time our kubernetes clusters are also
auto scaling so based on unfulfilled
capacity and unfulfilled requests the
kubernetes scheduler can scale up the
number of AWS instances that are needed
to fulfill those requests however that
itself starting a new instance can take
a while as well we use Packer which is a
packaging tool open-source packaging
tool for generating AWS a mis or many
other types of images this helps us
create the VM image pre-baked as it's
needed to
and abuse and it cuts down our yeah
in the original Packer builds it cut it
down from 20 minutes to 6 minutes or so
so we combine there's another thing we
need to do which is for notebooks you
want the experience to launch a notebook
really fast
however launching a new node can take up
to six seven minutes downloading the
image if it's not pre cached can take
ten minutes so we solve both of those
problems we create a warm cache of extra
nodes available for both CPU and GPU
types and that's a configurable limit so
kubernetes provides a great construct
called priority classes which we can use
to create lower priority jobs that can
be preempted with real workload this
allows us to specify extra capacity for
jobs that are just sleeping around and
they're they're just waiting to be
preempted by real workloads this allows
us to make the notebook experience
extremely fast we're able to provide
consistent notebook launch times within
10 seconds for these 15 gig images on
kubernetes this makes it makes the data
science super productive and that makes
us happy so once remember I mentioned
how your notebook code is residing on
NFS however in order to productionize
something we don't really necessarily if
you don't want to rely on some code
lying on NFS as our main source of
shorts so we provide good github
integration just from the UI a user can
go and set up their github credentials
they can go to github find it generate
and your token for their account and
register that in the credentials page
these credentials get translated to
kubernetes secret objects the kubernetes
secret objects is a it's a construct in
kubernetes to allow you to store
arbitrary secret
in encrypted format on the backing data
store called HCD these are encrypted at
rest and they can be mounted as part of
any job that gets lost on the cluster so
once you set up your github token once
you set up your hive credentials once
you set up your presto credentials then
we make them automatically available on
your container during any notebook or
training job creation so you can access
external data source for retrieving your
training data sets and the same way the
credentials are used for publishing new
code until github so github token is a
form of credential but access to hive
can also be another form of Prudential
and these are all configurable alright
so let's talk about training and
deployment once you've developed your
model and you just want to try out many
different variations of a model with
different optimizers a different
learning schedule let's say for deep
learning models it's very common to try
out different number of iterations for
the mini batch training so it involves a
lot of exploration and we want to make
the exploration really fast and all of
these jobs can run in parallel you could
large hundreds of jobs with different
learning rate or different optimizers or
any other parameters hyper parameters
that your model takes how do we do this
we create a really simple contract for
users to implement so as a research
scientist your notebook just needs to
contain our model for us with no extra
imports or anything you just need to
have a class named model and a bunch of
methods which will become automatically
become your entry points for different
types of jobs you want to launch so
let's go through all of those so here's
my model class and
the training method I'll go into all of
these in the future slides actually from
the notebook also we provide a custom
plugin which allows you to take your
notebook code along with any other code
around it from that base path in the NFS
pack of folders and package it all up as
a docker container so as a data
scientist I don't need to deal with any
kind of CI I don't have to deal with
involving an engineer to convert my code
and package it to a docker image I don't
need to understand how docker files are
written I just say hey by the way here's
my model here's my logical name for that
model and a version now go build a
docker image with that and you just can
pick a base image that they want to put
their code on top these base images
represent certain Python package
dependencies so let's say you're using
tensorflow in your model and you want to
use the base image which has cuda
drivers for GPU execution and a certain
version of tensorflow so you can pick
that base image as you're importing
image in your darker file and then
basically over layer layer your code on
top of it so for a user all you have to
do is click a button to generate docker
images we use darker in docker by
running a docker process inside dock
around kubernetes pods to build an image
and then push it to a registry alright
so let's get into the details of this
model contract it all starts by
initializing a model class with a
default set of hyper parameters so we we
automatically detect hyper parameters
set up on a model based on the hyper
parameters dictionary mentioned over
there the lists mentioned over there
where you define what are the default
hyper parameters what are their default
values and during job launch
you will automatically get a chance to
override these values if you want the
Train method becomes your entry point
for any kind of batch training if you
define some default hyper parameters and
you want to run ten different versions
of those with different values then it
will invoke the training training
endpoint for that we'll get to the UI
let's go back you see the training tab
over there so using the training tab you
can just pick a marble that you defined
through the same model button and you
can invoke a new run offline for that
model and with overwriting certain hyper
parameters that you care about and that
in turn invokes the Train method out
here now we provide two types of
predictions for your models let's say
you trained a model that performs really
well you're happy with it and you wanna
generate daily predictions from that
model every day I want to predict a
drivers likelihood of driving at a given
hour for example if I want to generate
that I can do that offline it doesn't
happen in real time it's an ETL job so
the ETL job we'll just call lyft learn
API with batch predict call which will
run the batch predict method as your
entry point for your model so you can do
different things and you have the
different end points available for those
if similarly if you want to run web
services on top of your model and make
it available as a web service for
real-time inference you just create a
predict method in your model class which
takes a dictionary of their features as
inputs so if user defines the predict
method we would automatically run a G
unicorn and flask server on top which
starts serving the predict method at a
canonical
endpoint slash invocations so as a data
scientist still no engineers involved in
the process of taking your model from
development to either offline prediction
or to web-based prediction and these
tools make it extremely fast for any
user to go from idea for a model to
running it as a product feature what's
the in it predict method the in ik
predict method is useful if you want to
do some kind of heavyweight
initialization for your predictions for
example you might want to load model
check points from s3 and that might take
a while so the init predict method is
called once at the initialization of
your prediction job that allows you to
do some heavy operations create a in
memory state and then run many
predictions really fast if you look at
this contract it's extremely generic
we're making no assumptions about what
kind of training job is running what
kind of predictions happening we're just
providing hooks for a user to run these
jobs at a given schedule or manually
through a UI or through command-line we
also provide easy command-line tools for
users to build docker images locally
with their models and push it into a dev
registry from where they can start using
the same features from the URI moving
forward hyper parameter search so so far
I've talked only about manual hyper
parameter search user is specifying
either through a Python script or
through the UI many different runs of
jobs they would like to launch
however for certain models like XG boost
or any kind of booster trees you have
very large number of hyper parameters
and you do very large exploration
studies across those kind of models
those explorations can yield real
significant improvements to your model
so for such type of models which require
very large scale iterations or expiry
mutation we integrated an open-source
tool called Khattab which is part of the
cube flow project for automatic hyper
parameter search so a user can perform
many different types of hyper parameter
search like giving us a grid of values
let's go here for example so you can
define different metrics you would like
to optimize and you specify either
a range or specified as a numerical
value with some kind of step count or it
could be a dimensional value with many
values for those and once once you
specify those you can also specify what
kind of instance you want to launch
these jobs on so you can pick is it a
high memory instance is it a GPO
instance is it a for GPU instance and
we're working on adding a cost limit
where users can specify how much money
they are willing to spend on these jobs
so the study will automatically run many
different iterations of these models by
using different combinations of hyper
parameter values and listen to metrics
being emitted through each of those jobs
in terms of the final performance
metrics for each of those jobs and then
a controller will make the decision on
how to tune certain hyper parameter
values in the direction where it
performs better and better so it's a
fully pluggable strategy which allows
for choosing different kinds of
controllers either you can use a really
dumb controller that just takes a bunch
of different hyper parameters and runs
every iteration of those or it could be
more like an a real optimizer
machine-learning optimizer which can try
to optimize all these values based on
its gonna try to fit the values to find
the optimal hyperplane meter values that
perform the best
it kind of looks like this this is the
UI that comes with the kata project
which is part which is a implementation
of Google's automatic hyper parameter
search system called Vizier you can it
can trigger very large number of
iterations on kubernetes and listen to
their metrics that it's trying to
optimize and based on that they define
the next set of hyper parameters to
launch we've seen really big gains in
terms of data scientist and research
science productivity from using these
tools because that can automate the
process of discovering the right hyper
parameters which can take several days
if you were to do that manually you
don't have to keep track of all the
different job states if you were to
launch them manually you don't have to
handle failure scenarios the controller
takes care of all of those so scheduling
so I spoke a little bit about batch
predictions and the way we integrate
this is through triggering the lift
learn API on a schedule using external
schedulers at lift we use airflow
heavily which is a very successful
open-source scheduler and we've provided
custom operators inside airflow which
hit the rest API for lift learn on a
given schedule and execute certain
models we also have some other internal
schedulers inside left and since the
REST API for lift learn is the primary
interface to have all the functionality
it's really trivial to integrate with
any custom scheduler we decide to use
some of the future work we want to do
better integration with github so we can
have stronger code review if a model is
developed we want to be able to hook
into get prev process more deeply so we
can track what our model what's the code
running for
given model running in production now we
also want to expand and make it easy to
create custom environments for your
notebooks let's say you just care about
certain types of libraries that no one
else does but you want to quickly start
using the the whole functionality of the
system you can do that we want to make
it easy to for it for users to register
new base images the way we've designed
system is we have the API layer that
that is highly pluggable and you can
push new images that you want to
register as software environments or you
want to push new hardware configurations
as your hardware resource options users
can also basically everything underneath
is kubernetes for execution and it has a
database that stores some metadata about
historical job execution so kubernetes
is not very good at storing very large
amounts of state historical state the
HDD data store is more designed for
current workload is not designed as a
data storage system so we use a meta
store Postgres type database for storing
historical runs there their status what
kind of hyper parameters were submitted
in order to run a certain training job
so that any user can replicate a
training job that was created anytime in
the past so by capturing metadata about
model execution and running it all on
kubernetes and using docker abstraction
we have the ability to replicate the
models any number of times you want and
so that prevents a lot of errors in
machine learning commonly seen around
not being able to replicate a certain
result or the data changing underneath
or the model code changing over time
affecting model performance by container
izing those models we freeze the state
of the algorithm that was run in order
to produce a certain result
we're working on open sourcing this so
that it can be available to a bigger
community if anyone's interested
definitely reach out to me in the office
hours I'm happy to talk more about it
thanks for listening do you still have
people at lyft running notebooks locally
or is this just like presented itself is
the most obvious solution for running
notebooks anywhere and everybody's all
in on this so in the very beginning we
launched the very first version of this
system in May and earlier people were
still hesitant because they had a very
well set of environment locally they
just didn't have big data sets they just
sampled it enough what they didn't care
about having a remote system but very
very quickly the adoption has been
insane like we have AI will have a very
high NPS almost 80 90 percent of the
research scientists use the system now
because when they started when they
finally switched over tried it out for
their near use cases they realized that
they can get a huge amount of power
unlocked because you get persistence of
your code over time you can get any
arbitrary machine configuration very
easily your code is actually shared
through NFS across all your instances so
you can develop on a smaller instance
but then you can scale out on very high
memory or multi-gpu instance so that
kind of flexibility that people really
love it and they don't have to worry
about closing their laptop and losing
the state all those problems are gone so
it's kind of eliminated the need for
local development completely now we also
provide cold syncing tools to make it
easy to develop in your favorite editor
and then just continuously sync your
code into the kubernetes parts that was
one of the big asks that was blocking a
lot of people not everyone cares about
developing in jupiter notebooks they
want to be able to use their favorite
editor so that was I guess like one of
the biggest features that move people
away from local development
other questions yeah thanks for the talk
um I was curious do you do you have also
engineers using this or is it just data
scientist and yeah that's a good
question so as I said before we have
multiple layers of multiple tiers of
users the researchers are less
programming oriented more on the they're
more they care about the machine
learning problem more they don't want to
get into details so the UI solution is
used heavily by the research scientists
the engineers seem to prefer to use
command-line tools so they are we have a
ton of command engineer users I think
that who use command-line tools more
than the UI one other thing is in lift
we from the beginning we've had a
distinction between a software
engineering role and m/l role so those
distinctions are getting more and more
merge now that they're going away so we
see more engineers using the ML tools
now yeah
so do you still have like a production
ization software like there's the
development of it in a jupiter notebook
and it seems like this could actually
like automatically spin up a service
that could then be hit from production
but do you still have like people taking
it taking a model developed by the mo
researchers and like production Eliza
yet to make it faster I think that's
that's a common problem we were seeing a
lot in the past we actually have the
ability to directly spawn a kubernetes
deployment based on the model you
generated using the print and it calls
the predict method that I talked about
earlier however was kind of putting on
the back foot and trying to better
integrate with CI and Jenkins and
deployment pipelines so we have good
traceability of what cords running for a
web service and how to roll back or
being able to inspect what's running
inside that code so we want to tie it
closely to github commits so right now
our way of doing that is just data
scientists will push the code to github
and we're working on making it really
easy to use the CI process at lyft to
launch production services from that and
we generate automatic monitoring and we
maybe manage the SLA for rolling out
those modules yeah
[Music]